ai
つかもよ
tan
goo
殺伐さあなた様が6本下まで移動しなきゃいけないんで獅子ってたぶん1時間半以上
かかるんですよ片道クロイツ1行ったり来たりするだけで3時間時間取られるんですよ
1日の8分の1今回私道教に家を借りましたぁーっ
でもね引っ越しじゃないで引っ越し者
って声響くな心情だから小エビ東京に行くことが多すぎるんですよ東京に行くことが
多くてで多くするとお金がもったいないからもうそれではいっそのこと東京で家を借り
たほうがいいんじゃないかという結論に至りましてこっそり東京で部屋を借りる準備を
しておりました
静岡で今までとりあえず位はあるんですけども東京に来るときにはここに泊まります
ここでも撮影ができる
静岡があの部屋ずないと撮影する気が起きなくて振れてちょっと色々忙しかったり徹夜
したりすることがあったんですけどもこっちにい遅れることによって東京に行っても
この部屋で撮影できたり止まったり被害でしなきゃいけないことを2日間かけゆっくり
やったらできるんで結構時間的にはなくになるのかなと思っております公がシンセ弾み
アミューズメントパーク
東京支店
どうだまたカーテンはないから全部モザイクさ
白いとりあえず白い
とびっくりしたまで神逆になってる終えまして浮きます
近所豆腐か信者ですかうんっによりますよ
いやあそこで所だこれすごいガンゾウにさあしているとされているところなんでこの
臭いんだろう
おかげさまですねそう線ペンタブキッチン福田持ってるって言うかと
なんかここゲーム事業で縫えばざまぁそういう曲は使ういますよりしないもんです
4 wd
実はここを決めたここはね編集0にする
ここでモニターおいてここに森田もういっこいって
及ばずする入ってあげてこの部屋に撮影することがたまにあるかもしれません多くなる
かも知れませんか食べる撮影は編集モコ2できるのでかなり時間の使い方をうまくいっ
ていればいいなと思っておりますぜひで東京編もよろしくお願いします
じゃじゃーん
ani
tan
えっ
me